[Music]
linda
is in san jose california hi linda how
are you
hi there thank you for taking my calls
sure how can we help
i have to i have two options so option
number one
is do i do a cash out refinance on my
property
to use that money to build a home in a
lower expense state option number two
is i can liquidate my brokerage account
which currently giving me
roughly between 16 to 18 rate of return
on my money and use that money to
um to pay for the construction of the
house
is there an option
sell sell the house that you are going
to refinance and cash out
and use that money to build the property
man
i've been around well i was going to do
that but option three can't be
there because we currently have a
business
and our children are still in college
and we
and why do you need a house in another
state yeah
well that was going to be my retirement
property okay when you get ready to
retire then sell the house you're in and
move over there
but you don't need to buy a house 10
years before you retire because someday
you're going to need it
yeah okay okay
well you are not going to do this she's
not she's not going to do this
so the reason i brought up about the
cash out refinance is because my
property is worth 2 million
and i only owe 200 000 on it so if i do
refinance and get the money out how much
is in your brokerage account
uh roughly 300 000. okay i'll probably
just pay off your house out of your
brokerage account
and be debt free and then let's go let's
just build a big pile of wealth over
here to the side
and when you get ready to leave sell the
two million dollar house which by then
will be worth more
and use some of your brokerage money or
whatever you need to do at that time
but you don't need to build a house that
you don't need
you don't need this other house well
what we've been doing is
we would like to have a property up
there where my husband and i can
work there three days a week and then
come back to california
four days a week and that's what we're
thinking because i need to get my
husband
somewhat away from this area where we
are it's very congested and i
want him to relax a little bit that was
my thought
it's more than just uh money so what
does the uh what's what is the property
going to cost that you're going to build
that you're going to live in halftime
we already paid the atlanta is debt-free
how much money do you need to complete
this deal
roughly 300 000. okay i would use your
brokerage money then yeah
well listen listen you called the ramsey
show
100 of the time we don't tell you to
borrow money yeah
100 of the time i would never tell you
to cash out to buy a second home
yeah do a refinance cash out on your
personal residence it means you can't
afford the second home
and i i would i would disagree with
showing the last part dave i'ma say
still pay off your house and then just
stack up the money for a year or two and
then go buy the other house
that'd be okay too you know um but if
you're gonna do the other house deal
yeah you know what i would do that
you're right because i wouldn't listen
the second house is a toy
zach your husband needs to relax buy a
vacation thank you dave
thank you yeah you don't buy a second
home which is a toy
until your present residence is paid off
until you pay cash for your second home
you got me on that
i thank you dave i was about to let you
go after that comment
let me go where i ain't going anywhere
let me go set me free
this is the ramsey show